قال تقرير للبنك الاوروبي للاعمار
والتنميه ان نسبه النمو تراجعت في مصر الى
4.1 في مؤكدا ان الطريقه الى خفض التضخم
شاقه وطويله في اشاره الى مخاطر اقتصاديه
متفاقم وشكوك في قدره القاهره على السداد
ديونها في المقابل اشارت الحكومه المصريه
الى انها اتفقت مع صندوق النقد الدولي على
دمج مراجعتين لاصلاح بينها تعويم
الجنيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما حقيقه الوضع المالي
والاقتصادي في مصر على ضوء التقييمات
الاخيره ومدى تاثيرها على الاستثمارات
الاجنبيه وما مدى تاثير تلك المراجعات على
الوضع الاقتصادي في البلاد بالنسبه للعمله
المحليه واسعار السلع الاساسيه اي افق
ينتظر الجوله الجديده من المفاوضات بين
الحكومه المصريه وصندوق النقد الدولي وسط
حديث عن اشتراطه تعويمه جديدا للجنيه
المصري واي انعكاسات محتمله لما سيرشح
عنها في ظل تفاقم وطاه الازمه المعيشيه
على المواطن المصري وما واجهه الربط بين
تبكير موعد الانتخابات والوضع الاقتصادي
الذي تعيشه البلاد في ضوء الالتزامات
المصريه تجاه صندوق النقد
[موسيقى]
مؤشرات الاقتصاد المصري تبعث على القلق
ومعركته مع المخاطر التي تنهكه والديون
التي تثقل كاهله مصريا تحيط بها شكوك بشان
قدره الحكومه المصريه على الافاء
بالتزاماتها الماليه ذاك ما تقوله تقارير
ما صادره عن جهات ماليه واقتصاديه دوليه
مرموقه تعددت بياناتها الا انها التقت عند
مخاوف تلوح في افق المشهد الاقتصادي في
البلاد وكاله بلومبرج قالت ان وضع القاهره
على قائمه المراجعه السلبيه مرده صعوبات
يواجهها بائعوا السندات الحكوميه في
استرداد العمله الاجنبيه الوكاله اضافت ان
صندوق النقد الدولي ينتظر من مصر ان تفي
بوعودها وان تنفذ صلاحات منها الانتقال
الى نظام الصرف المرن وكان الصندوق قد
وافق على منح مصر حزمه انقاذ بقيمه ثلاث
مليارات ثلاثه مليارات دولار غير انه لم
يجري بعد مراجعه اولى كانت متوقعه للقرض
المصري في مارس اذار واعتبرت وكاله
بلومبرج ان تاخر تلك المراجعه مساله خطيره
لحكومه قالت انها عاجزه عن الوصول الى
اسواق راس المال الخارجيه في المقابل اكدت
القاهره انها اتفقت مع صندوق النقد الدولي
على دمج مراجعتين للاصلاحات المطلوبه
واهمها تعويم الجنيه وصت تحذيرات صدرت عن
الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي نفسه من
ان الشعب المصري قد لا يتحمل موجه اخرى من
غلاء
[موسيقى]
الاسعار
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من القاهره
الدكتور عبد النبي عبد المطلب استاذ
الاقتصاد السياسي والتنميه ومن ديترويت
معنا مصطفى يوسف الباحث في الاقتصاد
السياسي والتنميه مرحبا بكما سيد مصطفى
يوسف سنبدا معك اذا تراجع في النمو زياده
في التضخم في مصر وايضا وضع القاهره على
قائمه المراجعات السلبيه ما معنى كل ذلك
بالنسبه للاقتصاد
المصري الاقتصاد المصري يعاني معاناه
شديده جدا نتيجه غياب مفهوم التنميه
الشامله يعني حينما نقيم تجربه الجمهوريه
الجديده منذ يوليو 2013 10 سنوات الماضيه
نجد ان العمله قد يعني انهارت من كل دولار
امريكي كان يساوي انذاك سته جنيهات و35
قرشا قبل بدايه الجمهوريه الجديده في 3
يوليو 2013 الان في السوق الموازيه قرابه
ال 40 جنيها والسي اي بي البنك الاشهر في
مصر يتم تقييم اسهم في برصه لندن على 46
جنيه للدولار الامر الاخر ان الديون
المديونيه الخارجيه كانت انا ذاك 43 مليار
دولار الان المديونيه الخارجيه اكثر من
165 مليار دولار كانت الديون المحليه
قرابه التريليون و2 جنيها الان اكثر من 6
وص ترليون جنيه غياب مفهوم التنميه حينما
تحصل مصر على معونات ومنح لا ترد من بعض
دول الخليج الداعمه للجمهوريه الجديده
باكثر من 100 مليار دولار ما بين منح ض
قرابه 60 مليار دولار طبقا لتصريحات الشيخ
محمد بن راشد رئيس وزراء
الامارات اكثر من 40 مليار هما يمثلون
العمود الفقري للاحتياط النقدي الموجود
بال البنك المركزي وبالرغم من ذلك يعني
نجد ان الانفاق 8 مليار دولار على العاصمه
الاداريه الجديده اكثر من 24 مليار دولار
على مشروعات للمونوريل والقطار السريع
والقطار الكهربائي وبدعه مليارات من اربع
لخمس مليارات ما بين قصور رئاسيه ومبان
حكوميه طائرات رئاسيه كل هذا الامر في حين
ان معدلات الفقر قد زادت بشكل دراماتيكي
يحاول بعض يعني المدافعين عن الجمهوريه
الجديده القول بان ازمه روسيا واوكرانيا
كان لها سبب هذا كلام غير دقيق لان صافي
الاصول الاجنبيه كان في ديسمبر 2021 اي
قبل شهرين من غزو روسيا لاوكرانيا كان
صافي الاصول الاجنبيه بالسلب يعني نحن
امام غياب مفهوم
للاولويات عدم
الادراك لان دعم الصادرات ودعم الصناعات
الصغيره ومكافحه الفقر والانفاق على
الزراعه والصناعه وعلى الاقتصاد الحقيقي
اهم بكثير جدا من المشروعات العملاقه
وخطوط النقل الفائقه السرعه تفضل لنستمع
في هذا المجال الى وجهه نظر سيد عبد النبي
عبد المطلب عن كل هذه المؤشرات ماذا تقول
لنا عن حقيقه الوضع المالي والاقتصادي في
مصر يعني بالتاكيد مصر بتعاني من ارتفاع
معدلات التضخم لكن ليست مصر وحدها يعني
واضح ان حتى اوروبا التي لم يتخطى فيها
التضخم لسنوات طويله حاجز الرقمين تخطى
خلال هذه الفتره حاجز الرقمين لكن هناك
مؤشرات جيده ايضا في الاقتصاد المصري هو
على الاقل هناك تراجع في ميزان في ميزان
في عجز الميزان التجاري و هناك تراجع في
عجز ميزان المدفوعات هناك بعض المخططات
التي بدات الحكومه المصريه بالفعل من ا
اجل
يعني العمل على تقليل حده المشكله
الاقتصاديه المزمنه والتي يمكن ان تنحصر
في عدم توافر العملات الصعبه اللازمه سواء
للوفاء باحتياجات مصر من الاحتياجات
الاساسيه مثل الواردات او حتى من اجل
تدبير ما هنا الازمه سيد عبد النبي هنا
الازمه يعني
كل ما تقوله المؤسسات الماليه المرموقه
الدوليه والمعني بمراقبه هذه الاوضاع في
الدول تق يقول ان هناك شكوك عاليه بشان
قدره الحكومه المصريه على الايفاء
بالتزاماتها الماليه وهذا ما يؤثر على
الاستثمارات
الاجنبيه لدى مصر
وبالتالي هل تستطيع السلطات المصريه من
دون هذه العوامل ان تخرج من هذه المشكله
الاقتصاديه التي هي
فيها يعني جزء مهم جدا من تقييم هذه
المؤسسات قائم على ان مصر لديها التزامات
لن تتمكن من الوف ب يعني التاريخ بيقول ان
مصر حتى في العهد الخديوي كانت على دائما
على اهبه استعداد للوفاء بكافه التزاماتها
مصر ما زالت حتى هذه اللحظه بتمتلك
احتياطي ضخم من
العملات العملات النقديه الاجنبيه بيغطي
ضعف الفتره القانونيه المطلوبه يعني يغطي
اكثر من سته اشهر واردات تستطيع الحكومه
المصريه اذا دعت الحاجه ان تلجا الى جزء
من هذا الاحتياطي لتوفير احتياجاتها من
الخامات ومستلزمات الانتاج وتعيد الحركه
ال السوق المصر لكن المشكله هنا ان مصر
تنتظر يعني كما هو موضوع حلقه اليوم
مراجعات صندوق النقد الدولي ولا تريد ان
تدخل هذه المراجعات ولديها بعض المؤشرات
السلبيه خاصه في مجال تغطيه الاحتياط
النقدي
ل لعدد اشهر الواردات لكن مصر لديها
احتياطي نقدي كبير المجتمع المصري ايضا
لديه كميات كبيره جدا من الدولارات يعني
لا اريد ان اقول رقم لكنها تزيد تزيد في
مجمل الثروات المصريه داخل مصر عن 150
مليار دولار يمكن ان تلجا اليها مصر عند
الحاجه حتى يعني كان هناك يعني الدقيقه
واحده في هذه الجزئيه يعني بدات الحكومه
المصريه من اجل اصدار شهادات استثمار
دولاريه بفائده 7.9% وواضح انها بالفعل
جمعت مبلغا جيدا تستطيع مصر ان تتدخل به
وتناول سواء في لاستقرار سعر الصرف في مصر
او لتمويل الواردات التي يمكن ان تعيد
للاقتصاد المصري ه كان هناك اقبال على
شهادات على ه الشهادات
هذه
بالتاكيد لكن يعني جزء ايضا من سوء اداره
هذه العمليه ان البنو البنكين الاساسيين
الذين يعني اصدر هذه الشهادات لم يصدر حتى
الان البيانات الخاصه بها لكن من واقع
يعني ما نرا لا بالفعل هنالك اقبال
وتستطيع مصر ان تزيد هذه الحصيله اذا سمحت
لباقي القطاع المصرفي المصري باصدار مث
السيد عبد النبي سيد مصطفى يوسف اذا يقول
لنا السيد عبد النبي عبد المطلب الحكومه
المصريه ل يها احتياطي نقدي كافن بالعملات
الاجنبيه لكن التصرف بهذا الاحتياطي
و يعني قلب الاوضاع داخليا ينتظر المراجعه
مع صندوق
النقد ما رايك مدايا يعني ما تفضل به
الضيف الكريم من القاهره نقطتان نقطه ان
العجز في ميزان الميزان التجاري قد قل نعم
قد قل لان لا توجد عمله اجنبيه فهناك يعني
تم انقاص بشكل دراماتيكي حجم الواردات
المصريه وه بعض هذه الواردات تدخل كمواد
اوليه في الصادرات المصريه وهذا امر مضر
جدا للاقتصاد الامر الاخر ما تفضل به ضيفي
الكريم من الاحتياط النقدي نعم الاحتياط
النقدي في مصر الان 34 نص مليار دولار
تقريبا اكثر من 28 مليار دولار يعني اكثر
من 80% من هذا الاحتياط النقدي ودائع
خليجيه لو قررت هذه الدول الخليجيه سحب
هذه الودائع سينكشف الاقتصاد المصري ولا
يتبقى الاستيراد السلع الاساسيه في مصر
اكثر من شهرين هذا امر في منتهى الخطوره
لماذا نحن نعاني بهذا الشكل لماذا لم يعلن
البنكين الذين كان لدي وكيل الطرح
للشهادات الدولاريه نحن مصر في مؤشر
العداله الدوليه وعلى مؤشر الشفافيه من
اسوا خمس دول في العالم نحن امام غياب تام
للشفافيه سيطره تامه على الاقتصاد من قبل
المؤسسه العسكريه ما قاله الباحث كبير
الباحثين في معهد كارنيجي يزيد صايق ان
اكثر من 75% من الاقتصاد المصري تسيطر
عليه المؤسسه العسكريه نحن امام ميزانيه
غير معلنه وغير معلومه للمؤسسات للمؤسسه
العسكريه وكذا للهيئات الخاصه اما يعني
الموزن العامه للدوله هو ما نتحدث عنه
يعني هذا امر معيب لانه ينبغي نحن امام
دوله واحده جمهوريه مصر العربيه ينبغي ان
تكون لديها موازنه واحده يصب فيها جميع
الايرادات وجميع الشركات حتى نستطيع يعني
الوفاء بالالتزامات الموجوده هل يستمر
الوضع على هذا الحال سيد مصطفى يوسف
رغم دخول صندوق النقد الدولي على الخط
ومطالبته باصلاحات معينه في هذا
المجال نحن يعني امام امنيه ان يعني تستمع
القياده السياسيه في مصر الى ما ينبغي ان
يكون والى يعني اقوال الخبراء سواء من
صندوق النقد الدولي او البنك الدولي او
الاقتصاديين سواء كانوا في بلومبرج سواء
كانوا في نيويورك تايمز سواء كانوا في
الايكونومست ذا جارديان يعني يعني هناك كل
الاقتصاديين في العالم اجمعوا ان المؤسسه
العسكريه ينبغي ان تتخرج تماما بالاقتصاد
ينبغي ان هناك وحده يعني موازنه موحده
موحده للحكومه المصريه لجمهوريه مصر
العربيه ينبغي ان تكون هناك شفافيه وارقام
معلنه ينبغي ان يتوقف الانفاق على يعني
الان لابد من طرح العاصمه الجديده والقطار
الكهربائي والمونوريل والعالمين والقصور
الرئاسيه والطائرات الرئاسيه مثل ما فعل
رئيس المكسيك يعني يعني اندرياس اورادور
لما طرح الطائره الفير الابيض كانت ب 218
مليون مليون دولار للبيع حتى يتسنى لهم
يعني يعني
الانفاق على الصحه والتعليم وعلى الجوع
حينما يزداد معدل الفقر في مصر بشكل درامي
منذ يعني في الخمس سنوات الاخيره وننفق
بهذا الشكل هذا امر حقيقه يثير يعني حفيظه
الخبراء ويجعل الاستثمار الاجنبي سيد عبد
النبي هل المشكله في
المراجعه المطلوبه من صندوق النقد الدولي
ام المشكله في ان الحكومه المصريه لا تنفذ
كل هذه الاصلاحات التي يطالب بها صندوق
النقد والاصلاحات اصلا المطلوبه لاي
اقتصاد كي يسير على السكه
الصحيحه يعني جزء مهم من تاصيل هذا
الموضوع ان القاهره عندما اتفقت مع صندوق
النقد الدولي كانت قد اتفقت على عرض جزء
من شركات المؤسسات السياديه او مؤسسات
الجيش في البورصه وكان هناك اتفاق على
ثلاثه شركات وان يكون هناك سعر صرف مرل
بالفعل القاهره بدات تنفذ جزء من هذه
السياسات وتم تخفيض قيمه الجنيه المصري ل
يعني مرتين متتاليتين لكن هناك بعض الامور
التي يمكن ان تظهر عند اجراء مثل هذه
الاجراءات وقد يكون لها تاثير خطير على
مستوى الحياه في مصر يعني انا هنا ما زلنا
نذكر نفس مطلبات صندوق النقد الدولي لمصر
في سنه في عام
1996 بضروره تعويم الجنيه وا واجراء وعمل
سعر صرف مرن وقتها يعني كان هناك مجموعه
من الخبراء وصلوا الى اعلى مستويات على
مستوى رئيس الجمهور وتم رفض هذا الطلب
بتاتا وقتها اعلن الصندوق فشل المفاوضات
مع مصر وبعد عام واحد حدث الانهيار في
النمور الاسيويه واثبتت مصر ان وجهه نظرها
كانت صحيحه هذه المره يعني تحدثي سيد عبد
النبي سيد عبد النبي السيد مصطفى يوسف
يتحدث عن ما هو ابعد من ذلك يقول لك انه
يجب ان يكون هناك موازنه موحده تصب فيها
كل الايرادات لا يمكن الاستمرار بموازنه
خفيه للجيش وموازنه اخرى للدوله بما يسمح
بان يستمر تدهور الاوضاع الاقتصاديه بما
هو عليه
الان يعني هذه النقطه كنت ساصل اليها بس
لكن بعد ان اوضح هذه النقطه الان وبعد
الدراسات يعني اوضحت الامور ان المصريين
قد لا يتحملون موجه جديده من من التعويم
يعني او مرونه في سعر صرف خاصه وان سعر
صرف الدولار وصل الى مستويات قياسيه لم
يصل اليها من قبل وكانت الدراسات تقول ان
هنالك احتمالات ان تحدث قفزات كبيره جدا
وقد يؤثر ذلك على يعني الحياه في مصر بوجه
عام النقطه التي تفضل بها الدكتور مصطفى
انا اعتقد ان لا يوجد اقتصادي يعترض عليها
وهو مساله وحده الموازنه وانه يجب ان يكون
كل الموازنات امام اعين البرلمان وان تكون
تحت سلطه الرقابه وان يكون هنالك شفافيه
كامله في عرض الارقام هذا امر لا خلاف
عليه المشكله الحاليه الحاليه انه من اجل
ان يحدث ذلك يجب ان يكون هنالك اعاده
هيكله لهذه المؤسسات ولهذه الشركات اذا
كنا نتحدث عن طرح اسهم شركات مملوكه للجيش
او للمؤسسات السياديه في البورصه فيجب
اولا ان يتم اعاده هيكله هذه الشركات وان
يكون لها ميزانيات وان يكون لها نظام
اساسي وان يكون لها نظام للافصاح ونظام
للمراقبه وان يسمح لمكتب محاسبه مدني
بالاطلاع عليها في ظل عدم وجود هذه
الاجراءات وهذه اللوائح لا يمكن ان تطرح
هذه الشركات
في البورصه او يتم ادراجها داخل الموازنه
العامه ما تفضل به الدكتور مصطفى هو امر
يعني لا خلاف عليه لكن اولا لكي يتم ذلك
حقيقيا وليس وهميا يجب ان يكون هناك اعاده
هيكله
واعاده يعني اعاده رسم للنظام الاساسي
لمثل هذه الشركات حتى يمكن طرحها
للمواطنين لان طرح في البورصه يعني يسمح
لكل المواطنين بالاكتتاب في مثل هذه
الشركات ولا يستطيع المواطن العادي العادي
ان يكتتب الا اذا كان امامه ميزانيه شفافه
وواضحه بل ومنشوره ايضا سيد مصطفى يوسف ا
كما ذكرت يعني كان هناك ربما تعويل من
جانب البعض على الاصلاحات التي يطالب بها
صندوق النقد ولكن دخول صندوق النقد واقراض
مصر ثلاث مليارات دولار ثلاث مليارات
دولار ما الذي افضى اليه عمليا حتى الان
بيع للاصول المصريه وتعويم للجنيه بحيث لم
يعد هناك قدره لدى المواطن المصري العادي
على تحمل غلاء
الاسعار ما هو المنتظر الان من المراجعه
المتوقعه المراجعه المقبله
المتوقعه دعينا نذهب الى جذور المشكله
يعني صندوق النقد الدولي في نهايه 2016
اقرد مصر 12 مليار دولار ثم اقرض مصر مع
الكوفيد في 2020 8 مليار
دولار عم الخليج السخي الذي اتى اين انفقت
هذه الاموال لماذا نحن فيما نحن فيه الان
يعني دعينا نتخيل ان هذه الاموال قد انفقت
على دعم الصناعات الصغيره وعلى دعم
الانتاج ومن ثم زياده الصادرات وتقليل
الواردات لم يكن اطلاقا لينهار سعر الجنيه
المصري يعني حينما اتت الجمهوريه الجديده
ب 6 جنيه 7 جنيه 8 جنيه للدولار كان امرا
مقبولا و متحملا ويعني عدد الفقراء لم يكن
يتجاوز 29 30% التقديرات الان من البنك
الدولي قرابه 60% من المصريين تحت خط
الفخر او يعني حول خط الفقر لماذا لانه تم
اساءه استخدام هذه الموارد يعني الان
الحلول بسيطه للغايه حينما تخرج الحكومه
المصريه باعتذار حقيقي ووجود اراده سياسيه
حقيقيه باننا لدينا موازنه موحده بان كل
الشركات المملوكه لاي مؤسسه تصب في خانه
الموازنه العامه للدوله بان هناك شفافيه
ورقابه كما تفضل الضيف الكريم من القاهره
حينما تتوفر هذه الامور لن يكون هناك
معانه صندوق النقد الدولي يعمل وكيلا
للدائنين هو يريد حينما يقرض مصر هذه
المليارات الثلاثه الاخيره وال 20 مليار
الذين تم اقراض النظام المصري في خلال ست
سنوات الماضيه يريد ان يسترد 23 مليار
دولار كيف يسترد هذه الاموال يسترد هذه
الاموال عن طريق وجود سعر صرف حقيقي و
وانفاق يعني يعني رشيد وعدم وجود قرارات
غير منطقيه يعني حينما الان تعرض كل هذه
المشروعات للبيع لا يعقل اطلاقا ان يتم
بيع الاصول المصريه مثل شركات الاسمده
والحاويات
وشركه يعني شركات يعني تضر ارباح كبيره
جدا على الموازنه المصريه بدلا من ان تظل
هذه الاموال يتم بيع هذه الشركات
واستبدالها بالعاصمه الجديده والقصور
الرئاسيه والعالمين الجديده وطائرات هذا
امر حقيقه يعني الخبراء حاروا فيه يعني
سيد عبد النبي عبد المطلب ما واجهه الربط
بين تبكير موعد الانتخابات والوضع
الاقتصادي وهذه المراجعات مع صندوق النقد
الدولي وما قد ينتج عنها من اجراءات
اقتصاديه قاسيه تستعد الحكومه او السلطات
المصريه عموما
لاتخاذها يعني اسمحي لي ان اوجه لحضرتك
خالص التحيه على هذا السؤال المهم لانه هو
لب الموضوع بالفعل عندما بدات الحكومه
المصريه تستشعر ان الجزء او التعهدات التي
تعهدت بها الى صندوق النقد الدولي ق قد لا
تتمكن من تنفيذها بالشكل المطلوب بدا هناك
نوع من انواع المفاوضات او اطاله امد
المفاوضات على امل تدبير جزء من العملات
الصعبه يؤدي الى زياده قيمه الاحتياطي او
عدم تدهوره بحيث تبقى المواسات الاقتصاديه
العالميه مرتفعه عندما حان موعد المراجعه
الاولى وكان مفترض في مارس الماضي ثم كان
المفترض ان تكون المراجعه الثانيه في
سبتمبر كان من الواضح ان مصر لن تتمكن تحت
اي ظروف من اجراء اي تخفيض جديد في قيمه
الجنيه المصري والا لن يتحمل المواطن
المصري هذا الامر وكان الامر يعني كان
هنالك خياران لا ثالثه لهما وكلاهما مر ان
يتم الاعلان
عن يعني فشل المفاوضات مع صندوق النقد
الدولي وانهاء هذه المفاوضات وبذلك كانت
مصر سوف تخسر الجزء التي كانت تتمنى ان
تحصل عليه وهو يعني دعم الشركاء الدوليين
يعني ما نتحدث عنه من قرض الصندوق هو قيمه
يعني لا تذكر لكن كان الامل في جذب دعم
الشركاء الدوليين سواء من خلال المساهمات
او زياده الودائع لدى البنك المركزي او
جذب الاستثمارات مند من الشركاء الدوليين
وفي مقدمتهم دول الخليج تبكير الانتخابات
الرئاسيه جعل مصر في موقف قانوني يسمح لها
بطلب ارجاء المفاوضات مع او المراجعات الى
ما بعد انتهاء الاستحقاقات الانتخابيه
وهذا موجود في ادبيات مؤه الدوليه وفي
مقدمتها صندوق النقض الدولي والبنك الدولي
ومؤسسه التمويل الدوليه وغيرها ومن هنا
مصر يعني اعتقد ان امامها على الاقل ثلاثه
اشهر من اجل التقاط الانفاس واعاده ترتيب
البيت من الداخل ولو انني انا بقى شخصيا
اعتقد انه سيد مصطفى يوسف هل نحن امام
اعاده التقاط للانفاس واعاده ترتيب للبيت
الداخلي من خلال تاخير المراجعه مع صندوق
النقد وتفكير موعد الانتخابات ام نحن
بانتظار ربما اجراءات تكون قاسيه مما
يطلبه صندوق النقد لا سما في موضوع المزيد
من التعويم
للجنيه نحن يعني في انتظار قرارات ستكون
شديده الوطاه على المصريين الذين يعني في
يعني تقارير كثيره اكثر من ثلثيهم الان
يعانون شضه العيش هذا الامر الاول الامر
الثاني الحل بسيط للغايه هو وجود الاراده
السياسيه الاعتذار بشكل قطعي من الحكومه
المصريه عن الانفاق الغير الرشيد الذي تم
في الفتره الماضيه طرح هذه المشروعات
الجديده من العاصمه الجديده والعالمين وكل
هذه المشروعات الغير مجديه اقتصاديا للبيع
ومحاوله تقليل وتقليص الانفاق الحكومي
الدار الذي انفق على ما لا يوجد طائل من
ورائه دعم المواطن هذه الرساله ستصل الى
المستثمرين الخارجيين سيضخ اموال كثيره
حينما يروا ان الحكومه المصريه
ستتقبل ان هناك ديمقراطيات تشاركيه وان من
تسبب في هذا الامر تنحى عن المشهد واتيت
بوجوه جديده تستطيع انقاذ الاقتصاد المصري
الذي عانى خلال 10 سنوات من سوء يعني
التخطيط الاقتصادي والانفاق الغير رشيد
اشكرك من ديترويت مصطفى يوسف الباحث في
الاقتصاد السياسي والتنميه وشكرا لضيفنا
من القاهره الدكتور عبد النبي عبد المطلب
استاذ الاقتصاد السياسي
والتنميه مشاهدينا وصلنا الى نهايه هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا
لمتابعتكم الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ان